we are now representing 12 women
and we will file the remaining cases uh
the additional five cases
in due course as we do our due diligence
you should also know that we've also
spoken
to more than 10 additional women
so more than more than 22 women that
we've spoken to
who have reported conduct similar to
that
laid out in our public filings
that's houston lawyer tony busby press
conference
on friday afternoon regarding what is
now 12
lawsuits either have been filed or will
be filed i think seven officially have
been filed we're waiting for five more
at least 10 additional
women involved all of the lawsuits filed
under pseudonyms
there has been nothing directly from any
of the women involved we just have the
lawsuits that have been filed by busby
and busby's been the main spokesperson
and that's where i have issues with this
i spoke at length about this on pftpm on
friday i'm not a big fan of how busby is
conducting this
that's separate apart from whether or
not desean watson did anything wrong
right that's a different issue and
there's now a legal process that will
decide whether to what extent watson did
something wrong
but there are some some inconsistencies
in busby's words there are some things
that just
bother me as a former lawyer regarding
whether to what extent publicity should
be sought for things of this nature
he claims this isn't about publicity
while he's publicizing it at a press
conference chris
it just doesn't fly for me he claims
it's not about money
when it clearly is about money when the
system itself is about money and that's
okay
the civil justice system is premised on
using money to balance the playing field
when the powerful have wronged the
powerless
that's how it works it's necessarily
about money so
there are aspects of this that bother me
as it relates to busby
the way he's conducted himself on social
media the way he conducted himself on
friday
those things bother me but that's
separate apart from whether or not
his clients have been
wronged in some way by desean watson and
again it's up to 10
could be 22 and at a certain point for
the average person who hears about this
we talked about this last week i don't
know what the magic number is that gets
you to say
oh god there's just too many i can't not
believe this
yeah but somewhere between 1 and 22 for
most people
i think that gets to the point where you
say it's too many once you get past
two i feel like you're like okay that's
i don't know
that doesn't look right and like mike i
agree with you you know busby
it is it bothers me it's fanfare that
it's like a show it's a publicity thing
it does seem a little bit that way but
that doesn't take away from the main
point here and that these things are
troubling from desean watson i don't
know any other way to say it
i mean it's it's troubling you know yeah
it's one or two
okay i don't know are they trying to
take advantage of a
rich and powerful guy or that's you know
vulnerable
but this many come on that's crazy
there's obviously an issue here
it's obviously a pattern of something
that desean watson like to do in his
personal
life and i'm not sitting here trying to
judge or anything like that but this
doesn't look good
certainly and he's got trouble in front
of him and like
like like i like how people are still
talking like oh oh there's still teams
interested in trading yeah right
get the hell out of here nobody's
trading for desean watson
that's insane everybody stop telling me
that i'm sick of hearing that
there's nobody that's gonna trade for
desean watson right now
how could you do that desean watson by
all accounts
just like we talked a little last week
like ezekiel elliott got suspended
with like way less stuff on there
deshawn watson if i had to just
bet right now i'd go he's going to get
suspended there's no doubt i just
i i would say there's no doubt and i'm
not trying to say guilty or not or
anything like that
but the way this looks this many women
you know the scene of
as a scene of it all right now like i
just have a hard time thinking that
you know deshaun watson's going to walk
away clean from this and and not get
suspended and have some other issues to
deal with here
and and the reality is for the nfl's
in-house justice system
as administered under the personal
conduct policy pr
drives so much of this yeah and right
and the the bigger this story gets right
and the more it it it detracts from
free agency from the new tv deals my god
how dare you put a story out there
desean
that undermines the victory lap the nfl
is taking last week
for its new tv deals i'm telling you
that's going to be a factor in this
because
there's so much play in the joints with
the personal conduct policy and the
investigative process they can do
whatever
they want to do folks if they want to
suspend him they can find a way to
justify suspending him if they don't
want to suspend him they can find a way
to justify
not suspending him so that's the problem
here
he's caught up in the gears of that
machine now we saw it last week the
letter was sent by lisa friel to tony
busby the investigation has begun
and part of the problem chris even
before we get to a suspension
because we've got 12 pieces of
litigation that eventually will be filed
maybe 10 more on top but possibly a
criminal prosecution although i don't
think that's going to go anywhere
because it's going to be very difficult
to prove guilt beyond a reasonable doubt
i don't think a prosecutor is going to
want to touch this case
because it ultimately comes down to the
words of two people with no
objective evidence prosecutors shy away
from cases like that
all the time but as this all plays
itself
out over a period of months if not years
what do you do with deshaun watson if
you put him on the commissioner exempt
list you know what that means
it means you got to pay him yeah the
texans have to pay him if they don't
cut him they got to pay him 10 million
this year in salary
if he's on the commissioner exempt list
for the full season that's one of the
reasons why no one touched antonio brown
after he was cut by the patriots in 2019
because the league wouldn't give anyone
a straight answer on whether or not
they were going to put him on the
commissioner exempt list and nobody
wanted
to pay antonio brown to not play right
well the texans have already
entered into the contract that's the
great irony here the safe harbor that
desean watson may have financially this
year is to show up
if he's on the commissioner exempt list
or if he's going to be put on the
commissioner exempt list
and make his 10 million because if you
don't show up you don't get it
if you do show up you get it but you
don't have to play because you've been
put on the commissioner exemplist it's
it's just one of the many complexities
chris
yeah of this situation and uh it's
getting more complicated all the time
now rusty harden who represents desean
watson
vowed last week that they will have some
sort of a response this week
my response to that is hey there's two
courts here there's a court of law and
there's a court of public opinion and
even though i don't like tony busby's
tactics
killing it winning he is winning in the
court of public opinion right
not not even close you're right he's
crushing it i mean there
there's no doubt i mean nobody really
even knows
anything about the side you know desean
side of the story
nobody knows anything tmz had a report
over the weekend that most people looked
at and rolled their eyes at that
that tmz says desean watson found
massage therapists on instagram because
his regular therapist was
unavailable due to the pandemic that was
the tmz report
and i don't know whether someone
actually thought that would help
but but the general reaction that was
oh really that's it yeah that's that's
your explanation for this
yeah that's that's that's not a good
enough explanation that's not gonna cut
it
really i mean it's not and you know one
we talk about like
the trade thing right like nobody's
gonna trade for him right now
and where i really look at it mike and
this i do ask you
like i i have a feeling it could go the
way you just discussed right there
you know could we possibly be seeing
such an
issue here that it goes down the lines
of
a few more girls come out few more women
come out
this thing's you know doesn't look good
all of that and do the houston texans
cut him
and does the nfl put him on the nfl
exempt list to where nobody can sign him
or do anything until some of this stuff
gets figured out
i mean i have a feeling that's that to
me and again we don't know and i'm not
trying to presume anybody
guilty or anything like that but just
sitting here
with the guy and you and me and we've
been following football our whole lives
and doing that
that to me seems the road we're going on
right now if you made me bet where we're
going that's where i think we're going
well i don't know where we're going but
it's amazing in less than a week where
we've come
yeah and it and and uh it just shows you
the craziest most unpredictable things
can happen
like that it can come up like that i
said last week chris if you made a list
if you had asked me last week to make a
list of the five players least likely in
my opinion to be involved in something
like this watson would have been on it
yes
right right that's what makes it even
more stunning so uh
one more one more quick little piece of
sound from tony buzz because this is an
important issue
that we've talked about from time to
time and busby himself brought it up on
friday as it relates to this suggestion
that somehow the texans
were involved in what's happened with
deshaun watson here's busby
and i need to dispel some silly rumors
yes i live on river oaks boulevard and i
live
near the mcnair family i don't know the
mcnair family i i wouldn't recognize
cal or however his name is if i saw him
on the street
this case has nothing to do with the
texans
has nothing to do with free agency the
timing i don't know anything about that
silliness and i
don't frankly don't care about it texans
are not a team that i follow
yeah i i don't know tony busby well
enough to know that his tell is that
when he takes his glasses off he's lying
but when you say i don't know who cal
or hal or whatever his name is and
you're the most prominent lawyer or one
of the most prominent lawyers in houston
you don't know that
cal mcnair is the owner of the local
football team when you ran for mayor
and needed his support and live in the
same neighborhood and you don't know if
his name is cal
or hal that's somebody who's trying too
hard to throw dirt
on something chris in my opinion yeah i
hear you there mike i
i mean i i have a hard time maybe buying
that as well
but i mean just just you know watching
that comment organically you know that
that night whatever
was that friday night you know i i i i
do
i do look at him right now and go okay i
don't think he's doing this
you know with in in cahoots with the
houston texans i i don't
i i have a hard time believing that um
so
let me give you my theory though let me
give you a theory because there's
there's different levels
and types of cahoots right something i
thought of last night and i haven't said
this and i haven't written it
but but it the collusion
doesn't mean that the texans
wanted this to happen or that the texans
went to tony busby and said hey you'll
never guess
what we're hearing from some of our
people you may want to look into this
maybe this is a way we can take this guy
down
right because he's trying to tell us how
to run our business this can be as
simple as tony busby has a client who
comes to him
with a complaint that tony busby
believes is credible
and tony busby is ready to go forward
with a lawsuit right
because he's very sensitive and savvy
about the dynamics of the market in
which he operates
he decides that it's prudent to give the
texans a heads up
and make sure that he has either their
blessing
or that they don't tell him don't do it
because if they tell him not to do it
and he decides
i'd rather have a relationship there i
refer the case to someone else
that stuff happens all the time
there are broader dynamics at play for a
prominent lawyer
in a city that could cause him to decide
this isn't the right case for me to take
on because it could mess up something
else
and it's that's it's that simple of an
item yeah
of collusion yeah just a heads up hey
texans
i'm gonna be doing this i just need to
know whether or not you have a problem
with it
and they very well may have said we
don't have a problem with it this guy's
making
making our life hell hey he's got a
little issue he's gonna have to deal
with well that's fine you got a client
thinks he did something wrong that's his
problem not art yeah i hear
so this it doesn't have to be an
elaborate conspiracy
it can be something that simple yeah i i
might i mean
i i hear you that way and you know maybe
there is i don't know i don't know what
to say to that i really don't i could
see that certainly
being an avenue that busby would take
when he first gets this information
and all of that uh there's no doubt but
man it's dicey
and all i can say is it doesn't look
good for desean watson and i would say
him playing in 2021 is in
severe trouble right now with the way it
looks here sitting in march all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports